[Musique]
moi je n'ai pas la moindre parcelle de
volonté j'ai toujours suivi les conseils
de maman
j'ai apprécié votre maman une b2
exceptionnel vous qu'il des juifs à même
de juger
fait tout
de même plaisir déjà
[Musique]
c'est un pur que tu aimes panneaux
millet
[Musique]
au
ciel ma mère alors marcel la jeunesse
bonsoir bonsoir jean pierre armand
bonsoir bonsoir alors marseille ça vous
arrive souvent doubler des films porno
comme ça de temps à autre mais ce n'est
pas une spécialisation le doublé qui par
exemple on a besoin dans la vie comme ça
on la vit non ça j'ai pas j'ai pas fait
que du porno ou wayne là dieu merci
d'ailleurs j'ai doublé pas mal de films
et ce qui paraît aberrant d'ailleurs
c'est que j'ai doublé les premiers
promeniez premier film des maritimes en
europe et vous la voix française de
maman au départ quand elle était venue
de top ce repas ouais et puis après
quand elle passait vedette fox c'était
une autre camarade qui était remarquable
de sud est bien sûr je double et audrey
on est alors maintenant ils ont pris de
l'âge quand même alors les derniers que
je vous blessez madame chalet winnie
terre je ne suis pas tout à fait c'est
ça qui est amusant dans cette profession
d hier vous en fait souvent des films
porno comme ça non pas très souvent par
une chute un temps
elle est beaucoup et puis le marché je
prends c'est râlant fait ça très bien on
essaie de travailler il n'y est pas
c'est en fait le bruit la série ça là on
travaille à l'image d'un seul
ne s'est pas toujours drôle cette grand
mère je suis grenelle sage aux
petits-enfants fait opaque le porno je
ne sais pas le doublage ou de tabulation
général mais pas le port un jeu de toute
façon je dis bonjour et j'ai mes
petits-enfants dit y est voilà le film
s'appelle remplissez - ce titre assez
ordinaire sans que ses énormes efforts
sont tous là mais je suis là et
particulière c'est moi ça non mais ça
serait fastidieux clair ça tout ouïe à
olalalala bon ben moi je vais penser que
c'est ça tout le temps
guan si vous avez vraiment l'air de
savoir bien de faire c'est un métier
j'aime peu de temps si vous êtes avec un
homme dans un livre vous allez faire les
bruits le titre va croire que vous lui
donnez beaucoup de plaisir finalement
informations contiennent
j'avais pas pensé à vous
parce que finalement le type croire que
vous avez beaucoup de plaisir alors
qu'il nous fait aucun effet finalement
que vous êtes capable de faire tous les
bruits de la jouissance du plaisir on
est l'invention quand même les fans
n'avaient rien à vous
alors jean-pierre toi tu as fait cheveux
courts et a fait ce film porno fois 2003
2004 2003 2007 c'est faux et mme rice
dans 17 ans en 17 ans alors là j'ai
toujours posé une question je vous dis
bon c'est vrai qu'elle est il qu'ils
font le haut et d'autres qui font le bao
oui le problème il essaime c'est que
souvent les metteurs en scène où les
producteurs engagent des comédiens way
qui sont débutants donc ce n'est pas
évident qu'ils puissent fonctionner
avant l'érection facilement alors ils
font ce qu'on appelle la comédie ouais
ils font le début de l'érotisme soft
qu'on appelle et puis ensuite quand
arrive le hard le comédien se retire ou
pendant que la caméra montre sur les
visages et arrive le buzzer
professionnel je m'excuse madame
l'emprunt qui lui fait la pénétration
ouais puis alors que ça se passe on
continue et on continue
on s'envoie pas que le jeune comédien de
20 ans qui est beau comme un prince et
qui s'accomplit la caméra ensuite romain
sur le visage peint ce temps le vieux de
la vieille donc je fais partie c'est à
dire il accueillera au dessin de la
pollution
alors maintenant deuxième question c'est
quoi le secret ja comment tu peux
demander comme ça sur sur commande n'ont
ils pas ce que je vais te dire que là il
ya plein de téléspectateurs que savoir à
mon niveau déjà il ya l'expérience ouais
il s'étend déjà tu sais te mettre en
condition c'est facile je me sente au
moins 30 secondes y en a trop besoin de
deux heures ouais puis derrière moi y'en
a qui arrivent jamais
puis déjà que lorsqu'il beaucoup de
débutants lorsque déjà une présence une
personnalité un comédien connu un bon
vieux de la vieille qui a 15 ans de
métier que dix ans de médecins qui sait
qu'il doit travailler avec cette
personne alors déjà le garçon un peu
passionné alors puis en plus de ça bon
moi j'ai une technique c'était ma
technique est simple c'est bon je pense
à rien ouais que là que mes partenaires
me plaise ou pas je travaillerai
normalement que je ne plaisante pas que
je me plaise ou pas ce n'est pas mon
problème toute façon au match aller les
femmes avec une fille tu trouve plutôt
moche oui je m'enfuis j'arrive quand
même à oui parce que je suis payé péter
une aubaine toit pour les femmes
non ça c'est ma vie professionnelle et
ma vie privée avant d'en parler après
allez donc qui en plus derrière moi j'ai
quand même bien temps de yoga donc
non non il ya cependant que c'est pas un
problème concentration c'est un problème
de mental je pourrai me concentrer pour
faire de ces normes je suis moi même à
la limite mais est ce que comme ans
était venu je dirais ce qu'au départ
comment tu as tu as découvert que
j'avais un don pour ce genre de film
comment ça s'est passé non ça s'est
passé chez moi dans le midi d'où je suis
originaire au capteur plus grand centre
naturiste de vote ouais et j'étais très
jeune à l'époque
un jour metteur en scène américain rich
meyer ou m'a demandé de faire des films
pour nous comment tu l'a rencontré à la
plage ah bon il invite tout nu dans huit
une image il a vu que c'était
particulièrement bien équipé voilà alors
il m'a dit il m'a dit est ce que tu veux
faire des films pour nous alors moi en
arrivant j'ai dit dans ma campagne dolby
digital ce qu'il faut faire eh ben il
faut baiser était payé un chili s'est
dit finalement c'est un bon job et je
suis calme maïs et sa mère vit tant par
jour en usine reste celle ci je suis
plein et j'appuie sur
l'amour et des créatures d'olive a dit
d'accord
pour bonheur pour un grand bonheur pour
moi ç'a fonctionné au premier couvre 1
alors lorsque s'agit pas là des années
ce qu'on utilise à yopougon n'existait
pas en france cette tournée à l'étranger
d'abord oui et lorsque le hard est
arrivé en france pour moi c'est une
facilité parce que j'avais déjà deux
trois ans de métier derrière
depuis six états les cinq six mille fils
à ma carrière cinq six mille fils j'ai
vu passer
oui l'isf non
c'est pas de béring c'est mon métier
j'ai vu passer un millier de jeunes
comédiens qui qu'ils n'aient pas été
connus qui entre temps sont devenus très
célèbre certains ou certaines et puis
bon moi je suis là dedans il s'enfuira
c'est vrai que des fois quand le t-bond
arrive plus à éjaculer au bout de
quelques scènes on met du lait nestlé
oui on prend un fait battre la n 9 de la
glère des fous du lait nestlé oui avant
bien comprend du lait puis l'affirmer
sang dans la bouche son du moteur
d'accord on ouvre la bouche alors ça
cool et puis ça a d'ailleurs ça c'est
tout un pan de raconter tout ça devant
marcel
elle était avant comme j'étais au
courant jet et c'est vraiment un sport
dit moi alors jean pierre lassus à
trahir un secret mais ces excuses moi
mettre ton sexe mesure combien
je ne sais pas trop 25 avait quand même
35 aux 23 précédents entre les deux
c'est 24
alors est à la maison maintenant
dernière question comment ça se passe
très bien
j'aime ma femme on fait l'amour tous les
soirs et elle sait ça et elle c'est sale
et très intelligente là on fait la
différence entre ma vie professionnelle
et ma vie privée donc dépassé à dire tu
tournes toute la journée le soir tu
arrives tu remets le couvert oui parce
que sans rien voir je ne
sais absolument rien
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu